the next question really relates to um
the general issue of calculation of
zakat could you explain to the
viewers in um a nutshell how that is
done there are two methods of zakat can
be
calculated because zakat is payable when
you have it for one year so you can keep
a daily record of what is your wealth
above the nisab level you can keep a
weekly record or a monthly record So
then whenever the nisab level is above
then have note down the date on 1st of
January what was the nisab you had
second of January what you have so what
you had in the 1st of January say 1st of
January 2007 so 1st of January
2008 it be liable for Zak then what you
had on 2nd of January calculated and
third of January or on weekly basis on
monthly basis but to keep a record of
all this is very difficult and you'll be
spending half the day in keeping the
record which will be difficult so it's
not practical at all the easier method
and the safe method where mistake
inshallah would be avoided
is picking one particular day in the
full
year and calculate it exactly one year
after that most of the people prefer
Ramadan because it is the month of
Charity and we get more blessings and
more rewards but Raman is not the only
month that you have to pick up you can
pick up any day of the year but it
should be calculated according to the
hij calendar not according to the solar
calendar so 1 of
January 2007 1st of January 2008 is
wrong it should be first Shaban or first
of Hajj but since Ramadan is the most
ped month first of Ramadan you can take
any day of Ramadan if you take first of
Ramadan calculate all the asss that you
have and next year
if it first of Ramadan 1420
hij then first of Ramadan 421st hij you
should see what amount you have now if
you calculate only on one day and see
exactly one hij later one Lun later it
is the safest method there can never be
any possibility that you will give less
zakat there can be high chances you may
give more zakat but nevertheless why if
you keep on calculating daily
then the level keeps on going up and
down but if you calculate one particular
day of the year whichever day you pick
up and if that happens to be the lowest
collection the lowest saving in the full
year yet you are paying the minimum
amount of zakat say on the 1 of Ramadan
you have 100,000 rupees as saving or
$100,000 a saving and that happens to be
the lowest saving in the full
year yet since the lowest you have to
pay zakat on what you POS for one full
year so you have to pay 2 and half th000
rupees or $2,000 on that amount it's
safe but it may be that it is the
highest saving of the full
year so your itself you may be paying a
little bit more zakat but you won't be
paying less but some people may think oh
it is a high saving that means you know
I may paying unnecessary more amount
there are chances you may pay more but
there no chance you'll pay less because
even if it is the highest and if you
think that you will try and catch the
lowest point the lowest point may keep
on changing it may be in the month of
shaan it may be in the month of rajab
may be in the month of Hajj and then if
you try and catch that point next day it
will again change so if you try and
catch that point there are high chances
you'll pay less Zak so best is to pick
up one point one day in the full hij
calendar and keep on scking that every
year and you'll be less assured that you
will never P zakat you may pay
more because if the wealth keeps on
fluctuating up and down you have to pay
on what amount you possess for the full
year yeah but the lowest point once
maybe Shaban the other may be Ramadan
the third may be Hajj maybe any month
the safest is to pick up anyone keep on
sticking to that year and inshallah
you'll never pay less you may pay more
sometimes 10 % more 20% more 30% more
it'll never be less inshallah so this
the safest method and it's the best
method and on this day whichever day you
pick up you have to calculate all the
savings you have whether in
cash what is your bank
balance what is the gold you possess
whether in the form of jewelry whatever
stock you possess whether in shares
whatever investment all this you put
together or your business the stock
trade of your business all put together
if you're due to receive some amount
from from someone even that has to be
calculated because he has given a bit
late but yet it's your property or if
you have given some loan to someone that
has to be calculated but if you have to
give some money to someone that has to
be deducted from your amount for example
you have taken a loan of $100,000 or
100,000 rupees and the total amount is
500,000 Rupees that you have in your
home cash in hand cash in Bank stock
everything so you have to minus from
500,000 100,000 so you have to pay zakat
on 400,000
but if you POS $ 500,000 and you have
given loan of
$200,000 to somebody else and you have
to receive
$100,000 because Goods we have sold so
500 plus 200,000 plus 100,000 you have
to pay zakat on
$800,000 so in all you have to calculate
on one particular day of the year and
then you have to pay zakat 2 and half%
on that